kind of agree yeah so what i'm saying is
is women don't seem to fit like i don't
know a lot of men in real time that are
leaving their woman because she gained
weight
but i do know a lot of women that out
earn their boyfriends or their husbands
and leave so what i'm saying is women
don't face the consequence and then men
do
no i totally disagree with it i can't
see how this even makes sense
because it's frowned upon when men do
certain things so you know if i leave my
wife because she's fat everyone is going
to hate on me yeah you'll get shamed for
one thing i would say but you do that
all the time rather you'll get shameful
you can't even call you can't even call
women in fact now but they can call you
short though
you have to remember as well we're not
talking anecdotal we're talking this is
the statistical data to prove what's
going on
listen statistics are the same thing as
an anecdote you have to collect the data
points and that is through sight the
person has to actually be collating the
data so they're going to go and get the
data so that's that's the normal
but the problem the problem with this
thinking is then it's just whatever like
and i hear this a lot from women where
it's like we can't trust the data but
then what do we trust we just each
individually know where the data has
come from you need to know the sample
you need to know the sample sizes
for them because yeah i'm sure when
there's a cause that you know you feel
for and the data i am like
what you think no
you wouldn't say if you wanna if you
wanna question individual studies fine
if you want to go in and maybe inspect
the data more fast like i i
i say everyone has the right to do that
but with with the divorce statistics
it's pretty it's pretty cut and dry
i'm literally like but what are the
reasons and saying financial i'm like
yeah it could be financial but what was
the dynamic of the relationship where
finances were cited but even we know
yeah
but finances do they do affect it
because most women if you earn less than
them there's a certain level of respect
they just won't give you
and you know what i'm saying and you're
not speaking to me a certain way in my
house not happening they'll support you
for like a period of time but after that
dynamics that i'm more interested in
like that thought that that kind of
thought like so then respect was of
course there's a certain level of
respect a woman is not going to give you
if she knows she's out earning it
because she had the money she can get a
lawyer and she can leave i understand
that and i have nothing against that
it's just to be like a woman is leaving
because she's earning more no what's the
reasons why and because she's
disheartened
okay so but there has to be a disharmony
and that is the disarmament is the fact
she's earning more
would it not be because the man is
feeling honestly about it but she's
leaving you all living okay so i've ever
so this is what i've seen and guys i
mean from a man's point of view you can
tell me if this is accurate or
inaccurate i found if a girl let's say a
girl gets a promotion she's making half
a million a year is she going to submit
to the guy and say you get to make all
the financial decisions in the house
impossible
do you guys feel like most girls that
you've dated would be cool with you
being 100 in charge of the money
and say no i would like i would still
like you to make all the decisions but
when it becomes more practical and she's
the breadwinner the dynamics change
really fast because then she's trying to
tell you mate what's the dishes
that's it
i'm working hella hours and i'm not
going to come home to a dirty kitchen
right now this is good
it's like most men would say oh if my
wife put on weight after having kids
that i'm going to be with her forever
and never cheat but when she's looking
like 200 pounds heavier and then your
sexy sex tree comes in you might slip
into a vagina by accident
bro
you're loyal but bro it's the madness
and also yeah like updated women here
that make good money maybe not more than
me but good money and most women don't
like spending money on you anyway so it
don't matter how much you make
i'm not even gonna lie because i always
end up spending the majority of the
money in the relationship regardless
they spend their money on themselves as
many always deployed the idea that your
money is your money as a woman but my
money's out our money yeah that's how it
works see it differently 100 especially
if you come from that kind of upbringing
in it so i always i'll always pay most
of the time so these girls are living
life they're going on holiday with their
friends with the money that they should
be spending on man
you know what i mean
what's she doing on that holiday you
know what i'm saying that
you know you know what i'm saying but
what's up you know better though i do
think that's mental if you have a girl
that's not spending on you and you're
still with her that's that's your
problem what are you going to do run her
down for a pee is that what you're on
i'm sorry if if she's with you and
you're she's not doing anything not
paying for anything at all not even one
day that's on you so what you're sitting
at the table and you're saying to my man
with a chip saying you'll bring that
over there um if all of my birthday my
wife doesn't take me out it's finished
yeah but if you're in if you're with a
nice girl that's actually into usual
often no bro i'm sure i'm sure all of
you have had at some point a girl that
that's obsessed with you
a woman will go and spend money yeah but
there's offering there's always one at a
time there's offering and there's
i am paying but that's the thing when
you're seeing the pattern of her not
just offering and not actually doing
it's on you to then be like okay she's
not actually doing this why should i do
the same because that's character what
do you mean by characters that's her
character then so i think it's on the
man but that's what i'm saying
i'm agreeing with you if you're with
somebody and that's their character that
they are inherently selfish
where's the accountability and i picked
a super selfish person but going back to
the five like earning half a meal
is that fair that i would be earning the
half a meal and you get to make all the
decisions of course it's not well it's
not it's not fair but what the problem
is is when you start leading in a
relationship we're not attracted to a
guy that we can just like that's whipped
yes
so i think there's more of a
shared pot
if i'm the breadwinner it goes into a
shared pot i don't think i would turn
over what i'm earning
and then somebody else who isn't earning
the same is like this is how it's being
spent
i understand what she's saying but this
is what i'm saying about the respect
thing do you know what i'm saying this
is the thing so actually i have a
question for you so um you said
accountability for picking the wrong
partner
um do you feel the same way about women
that pick cheaters and or abusers yeah
okay so so you you believe it's equal
you're accountable for the people that
you pick yeah yeah yeah it's vibrational
okay
i need to elaborate on that one it's
vibrational i think that after you've
gone through it
when you come out of it
there has to be some type of
accountability i think if you've
actually do i
how did that happen how did i allow it
to take place what was taking place in
the dynamics of the relationship and i
was there it's still on the person who
did the cheating because they did the
act but you there is some type of
complicitness to it and if you take the
person back and you stay with them and
they do it again yeah it's your fault i
i i agree
do you think most women think that way
no no i actually
okay
no okay outwardly okay but i think
internally they actually beat themselves
up and they do but then they gain the
same situation again so what does that
say because vibrationally they haven't
learned but what do you mean by that
because they've got themselves
but you need two people that are in
attraction to each other so they are
still in a lack they're still in an
insecurity and the person knows i can do
this to this person because they are not
full of themselves but maybe they just
like the thrill of that because i i one
thing i've noticed a lot with girls is
that you know you'll be of a guy who's a
scammer you'll be a guy who's a drug
dealer and then complain when he scams
you and cheats
so if you're if you are attracted to a
scammer you are a scammer
of course because if you're okay with
him doing that then you're doing it i
know when he stands on you
if you get cheated on it's your own
fault like you picked up
it should be that way but this is where
i see the problem with self-awareness in
a modern society a lot of people claim
to be self-aware and understand
themselves but they really they don't if
you're making those decisions and then
complaining about the outcome of those
decisions it doesn't make sense so a lot
of girls look for avenues to absolve
themselves the responsibility of the
problems that they create one of them is
western western horoscopes